you don't grow unless you go out of your
comfort zone and that's in every facet
of your life if you want to become
smarter you have to read books or go to
school like that's not always
comfortable there's a million different
varieties of this but yes we are in a
culture that prioritizes comfort and
luxury and it's all about making our
lives easier
ironically what makes us happy is
putting ourselves in difficult
situations not so difficult that they
capsize our lives but difficult enough
that we're testing ourselves and we're
grappling with obstacles and we're
overcoming them and on the other side we
feel a boost in self-esteem we feel more
ourselves we feel more alive and we
experience growth and connection with
self and connection with other people
this is the stuff of life and yet it is
not
the way that Society is constructed